ميدان الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه يقف على
جانبيه طرف الصراع واختبار فصل الشتاء لم
يحسن بعد ومع دخول النساء
شرقيه اوكرانيا فيما يعيد كل جانب حسابات
اعاده التجهيز العسكري وشحن الامداد
وتنظيم تحركاته العسكريه
صوره تعكس طول امد الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وان لم تغيب عنها مشاهد
الاستضافات المتبادله على مناطق السيطره
العسكريه روسيا تواصلوا قصف البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه دون هواده اما
اوكرانيا
من التقدم الميداني في ظل تراجع روسي على
الارض
[تصفيق]
تراجع وكبه رصد من قبل الغرب الدائم
لاوكرانيا وسيناريوهات تطرح حول مستقبل
النزاع من قبل قاده عسكريين واستخباراتين
على راسهم اذر الهندس مديره الاستخبارات
الوطنيه
اكثر في ما يخص الاوكرانيين ضمن الاطار
الزمني الحالي
تفاؤل امريكي لصمود القوات الاوكرانيه
التي يحظى بعد عناصرها بدعم وتدريب من قبل
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه وبيان اخير لها
يؤكد تراجع التاييد الشعبي للحرب الروسيه
اظهر مسح الرسمي سري ان
25% فقط من الروس يريدون استمرار الحرب قد
يواجه الكريم لين صعوبه متزايده في الحفاظ
على موافقه الشعب على الحرب
توقعات غربيه قبل تعكس عناد التخطيط
العسكري الروسيه حيث اظهرت صور عبر
الاقمار الصناعيه قاعده للجيش الروسي بنيت
في مدينه
الساحليه التي تؤمن ممرا بريا بين
القرمباس وتعطي سيطره على الساحل
الاوكراني المطل على البحر الاسود على
السمان العربيه